[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning the
humanitarian crisis in ukraine has put
the spotlight on alleged racism the
concern immigrants from africa and other
people of color who've called ukraine
home now as millions flee the war-torn
nation there are accusations of
discrimination towards these refugees in
this country it's gotten the attention
of the naacp and the urban league
they've written to the president of the
eu calling for fair and humane treatment
for all
from virtually day one of the war
reports of discrimination at the ukraine
border began to surface
mostly they would they would consider
white people first twice we professed
indian people arabic people
before black people we went to the to
the train station and they wouldn't they
would not let us end and when when they
did let us end it they were like you
have to give us money because this is
this is not this is not for free for you
because you are frugal this is not free
for you on social media some wrote it
off as russian propaganda
ukraine's minister of foreign affairs
dimitro culeba tweeted this video march
second stating an emergency hotline had
been established specifically for
african asian and other students wishing
to leave ukraine i just
feel
deep sadness historian kimberly saint
julian varnan has been studying race
foreign policy and russia for years and
called ukraine home back in 2013. when i
initially saw the videos you know i was
just like
not again
you know it's one of those things where
if you are a person of color and you
work in eastern europe and you research
eastern europe racism isn't new i mean
racial discrimination is not new but
to see it
on display and being exacerbated by war
it was just really heart-wrenching
especially she says when considering
syrian refugees who in december sought
help at the poland belarus border with
little to no success so i try to point
out this this crisis we saw in december
because it is very much
the same situation of people fleeing a
war
and needing protection and care but
they're not getting that what is the
difference and why is there a difference
i think the key difference is race and
ethnicity i mean we've seen it in
reporting and how people have said this
but also like the the bulgarian prime
minister saying these aren't the
refugees we're used to these are
educated refugees while social media has
helped expose racial discrimination
saint julian varnan says it has also
been used by russia to spread
disinformation they use these videos of
these african students and these indian
students talking about racism and their
experiences of racism and they're using
it to undermine the ukrainian war effort
students from africa and other countries
make up a small population but as saint
julian barnen explained it's not okay
for people to be discriminated against
in this way she is in touch with several
students who made it to hungary and
tells me that many of them now
considered third country nationals have
been told that they have to move to
another country or go back home within
30 days i think you know i've gotten a
lot of messages from different people
about this story i'm glad that we were
able to highlight it a lot of people
talking about it on social media um but
it also brings into
um perspective the importance of not
just recognizing this typical you know
this specific humanitarian crisis but
there's others you know other refugee
crisis syria afghanistan south sudan
myanmar
and we need to remember that ongoing as
a country as a world and learn from this
moment again it's important to show it
yeah to tell people this is going on